first on CBS this morning a new survey
by the investment giant Blackrock
suggests tens of millions of Americans
still haven't started saving for their
retirement only 52% of women say they've
begun to put money away compared to 61%
of men Americans who have a retirement
savings plan say they feel a greater
sense of well-being
Blackrock is the largest money manager
in the world with almost 6 trillion
dollars in assets
it's president Rob Pepito is with us now
good morning good morning so let's talk
about some of this data in this report
because only 45% of those surveyed said
they were confident that they would
achieve an ideal retirement why such a
low number well this is a very very big
problem first of all people don't think
about retirement they kick the can down
the road and now that we know that
people are living longer they have not
saved or invested enough for that last
10 to 14 years of their life why aren't
they doing that high cost of living
housing cost health care cost and a lot
of parents would rather spend on their
kids today than save for the retirement
for themselves there's also a lot of
excuses it's too complicated there are
too many choices but we need to create
awareness that you cannot invest for the
future in the future and this is going
to be a growing problem in this country
so we try to do surveys create
technology create tools so that people
can get educated but the first part is
creating awareness that you have to
start saving today yeah have that
conversation discussion with your family
today we mentioned technology how could
technology help along this process well
you know technology seems to be solving
most problems so the first part is to
create awareness we have a website today
that's going up ww Blackrock comm slash
investor pulse this is going to create
awareness for people of what they need
to do and why they need to do it and
then what we've been doing is creating
tools for financial advisers so that
they can educate their clients we have
one called I retire very simple you get
you put in the money you have what you
think you're going to need it creates
diversified portfolios for you so that
you can understand that you can do this
in a very conservative way and that
information is going to help people to
make good long-term investments that
they will be able to have for their
retirement in the future look at this
graphic among the top concerns for
adults our health care cost that's
becoming a big issue going into this
next election season we have discussions
now about Medicare for all doing away
with private insurance we know that 150
million Americans get their insurance
from their employers how should they be
approaching health care in terms of
saving for their retirement well we know
that there's a high probability of it
going up but most importantly it's
uncertainty so why would you take the
risk when you're older you probably have
more health care costs so therefore it's
another reason to save but there's
something really important that we found
in this survey and that there's a
connection between wealth and well-being
and the number one thing that causes
stress amongst people is money and
especially when you're investing for the
future so we have found that people have
who every started retirement plans
actually have less stress and more
emotional dividends that tip at the
sides financial dividend we're limited
on time but great advice that much great
conversation thank you